ciao maryners e bentornati nel mio
canale se siete nuovi benvenuti oggi
parliamo ovviamente di tik tok
se non l'avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi
al canale non vi costa nulla ma per me è
importantissimo anche perché stiamo
arrivando a un milione sia qui su
youtube che su tiktok quindi mi raccomando
seguitemi anche lì partiamo subito
ma cosa stai facendo?
o zio sto dando da mangiare alle mie viziatine cosa vuoi saperne tu
quale imparo adesso quello ok che già
un pó lo so vediamo che filtri
nuovi ci sono oggi oddio questo qua lo volevo troppo provare adoro che cute
bello i denti un pó così peró é
carino ma che senso guarda che guanciotte
quanti like quanti like mary dobbiamo
andare baby here boy scusa you crazy damn boy
ma mary martha dumptruck in the flesh stiamo uscendo here comes the cootie squad
we should shut up heather sorry heather tu sei malata lo sai vero?
marina stiamo tutti uscendo vuoi venire
con noi oddio si hai ragione pronto scusami
no non posso piú uscire perché una
notizia bellissima charlie d'Amelia sta
per iniziare la live e non posso perdermela
cioè lei é la mia queen non hai capito
cioè io vivo perché lei vabbè ciao mary ciao
sai quando ti ho visto pensato si sarà fatta male
perché gli angeli come te
cadono dal cielo
o questo ha spaccato facciamone un altro
puoi chiamarla stupida puoi chiamarla
cretina puoi chiamarla idiota ma ricorda
che non puoi sputare nel piatto dove hai
mangiato la parmigiana
anche perché adesso quel piatto é il
piatto preferito di qualcun altro che non sei piú tu
ma guarda un pó quello che non si
voleva scaricare tiktok ma dai no io non
me lo scarico é una roba da bambini l'ho
scaricato solo per guardare i video
degli altri ti pare che mi metto a fare
queste cose ma figurati infatti ci
mancherebbe altro oddio guarda questo
che cringe no ma fa vedere il tuo profilo
ma che fake cioé user 0784 dai nome in
codice ma questo é uno
stalker secondo me ci guarda tutti i video
fa vedere chi segui charlie d'amelio ma allora sei
proprio diventato un fan di tiktok l'ho dato l'altro giorno a mia nipote e mi ha seguito lei si si...
marina ma cosa stai facendo ma ma come sei vestita duh mamma é una nuova moda e- girl
purtroppo siamo arrivati alla fine
del video spero tantissimo che vi sia
piaciuto mi raccomando fatemi sapere se
volete la seconda parte e soprattutto
fatemi sapere nei commenti quali
tipologie mancano oppure a quali
tipologie di questo video vi siete
ritrovati in particolare vi mando un
bacione grande ci vediamo al prossimo
video